>>> JPMORGAN CHASE CEO JAMIE
DIMON HAS THOUGHTS AND IS
WARNING DEMOCRATS THIS ELECTION
CYCLE WATCH WHAT YOU SAY ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP AND HIS SUPPORTERS.
>> I WISH THE DEMOCRATS WOULD
THINK MORE CAREFULLY WHEN THEY
TALK ABOUT MAGA.
WHEN PEOPLE SAY MAGA, THEY'RE
LOOKING AT PEOPLE VOTING FOR
TRUMP, AND THEY ARE SCAPEGOATING
THEM THAT YOU ARE LIKE HIM.
BUT I DON'T THINK THEY'RE VOTING
FOR TRUMP BECAUSE OF FAMILY
VALUES.
HE WAS KIND OF RIGHT ABOUT NATO.
KIND OF RIGHT ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
HE GREW THE ECONOMY QUITE WELL.
I DON'T LIKE HOW HE SAID THINGS
IN MEXICO, BUT HE WASN'T WRONG
ABOUT CRITICAL ISSUES.
AND THAT'S WHY THEY'RE VOTING
FOR HIM.
I THINK PEOPLE SHOULD BE MORE
RESPECTFUL OF OUR FELLOW
CITIZENS.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE A GOOD
JOB WITH THE DEPLORABLES.
.
CAN WE JUST STOP THAT STUFF AND
GROW UP AND TREAT PEOPLE WITH
RESPECT AND LISTEN TO THEM?
THIS NEGATIVE TALK ABOUT MAGA
WILL HURT BIDEN'S CAMPAIGN.
>> YOU RARELY, IF EVER, HEAR
CEOs OF HUGE COMPANIES BE THAT
CANDID ON POLITICS, TWO, JAMIE
DIMON HAS BEEN NO DEFENDER OF
DONALD TRUMP.
YOU'LL REMEMBER HOW HE WENT
AFTER TRUMP'S RESPONSE TO
CHARLOTTESVILLE IN 2017.
HE HAS BEEN IMPRESSED WITH NIKKI
HALEY SO FAR.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS IN THE BIG
PICTURE.
WE HAVE LEE, MATT AND LEAH.
LEE, LET ME START WITH YOU ON
THIS.
WHAT'S SO INTERESTING ABOUT WHEN
JAMIE DIMON TALKS ABOUT
POLITICS, HE TELLS YOU WHAT HE
REALLY THINKS?
>> THE POINT HE MADE THERE IS A
LOT OF WHAT TRUMP DID PROVED, IN
HIS OPINION, TO BE CORRECT EVEN
IF YOU DON'T LIKE SOME OF THE
STYLES, SOME OF THE THINGS SAID,
ET CETERA, AND BEYOND THAT.
SO MY QUESTION, IS THAT WARNING
DEMOCRATS SHOULD HEED AND THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SHOULD
HEED, ABOUT HOW YOU TALK ABOUT
SUPPORTERS?
THAT'S THE MESSAGE HE WAS
SAYING.
SHOW RESPECT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT TRUMP FOR
THESE REASONS.
>> IT'S A WARNING TO THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN AND FOLKS AND HOW THEY
COURT POSSIBLE INDEPENDENTS AND
MODERATES AND TO THE BUSINESS
WORLD, YOU NEED TO SURROUND
YOURSELF WITH PEOPLE WHO DON'T
THINK EXACTLY LIKE YOU, BREAK
OUT OF YOUR BUBBLE A BIT.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN ARE TOO MANY
CORPORATIONS AND COMPANIES
WALKING IN HEADFIRST INTO SOME
BAD PR OR BAD ISSUES BECAUSE
THEY DON'T GO AROUND THE TABLE
AND TALK TO ANYONE WHO VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP AND IT CAN HEAD OFF
A LOT OF ISSUES.
IF YOU HAVE A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE, IF EVERYONE THINKS
THE EXACT SAME WAY YOU DO
WHETHER IT'S A BOARDROOM OR
ANYTHING, THAT'S A RED FLAG.
>> JAMIE DIAMOND FOR PRESIDENT
IS THE RIGHT MESSAGE.
>> I THINK BIG ACKMAN TRIED
THAT.
HE DID.
NOW HE'S MOVED ON.
>> HE IS SO RIGHT, RIGHT?
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE MOMENT
HILLARY CLINTON LOST THE
ELECTION IN 2016, IT WAS THE
MOMENT --
>> THE DEPLORABLES.
>> THAT WAS GAME OVER.
WHEN YOU GO AFTER THE SUPPORTERS
INSTEAD OF THE CANDIDATE, BIG
PROBLEMS FOLLOW.
JAMIE DIMON IS A CEO OF A
COMPANY WHERE, IN AMERICA,
PROBABLY HATCH HALF OF HIS
CLIENTS VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP.
HE HAS TO HAVE A MESSAGE OF
UNITY, BUT I THINK HE'S RIGHT.
HE WENT ON TO TALK ABOUT HOW WE
HAVE TO STOP ACCUSING PEOPLE OF
BEING LIKE THE FORMER PRESIDENT
INSTEAD OF LISTENING TO
UNDERLYING CONCERNS.
MAGA REPUBLICANS, REPUBLICANS
AT-LARGE, HAVE VOLUME I HAD
CONCERNS.
THEY'RE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
DEMOCRACY, INFLATION,
IMMIGRATION, THE ECONOMY,
THEY'RE GOOD PEOPLE, MANY OF
THEM, AND I THINK JAMIE DIMON
HAD A VALID POINT.
>> I THINK IT'S ONE YOU CAN SEE
REFLECTED IN A VERY DIFFERENT
APPROACH THAN YOU HEARD IN IOWA
ON SUNDAY.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> SO WE HAVE TO HAVE FAIR AND
FREE ELECTIONS OR WE DON'T HAVE
A COUNTRY.
BUT THAT'S CAUCUSES ARE YOUR
PERSONAL CHANCE TO SCORE THE
ULTIMATE VICTORY OVER ALL OF THE
LIARS, CHEATERS, FRAUDS, FREAKS,
CREEPS AND OTHER QUITE NICE
PEOPLE.
THAT'S A MOUTHFUL.
>> I WAS BEING SARCASTIC.
>> THE THING I DON'T UNDERSTAND,
AND I'M NOT CRITICIZING JAMIE
DIMON OR THE VIEW OF WHAT HE'S
SAYING OR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON.
TRUMP SAYS AWFUL THINGS ABOUT
DEMOCRATS AND SUPPORTERS OF JOE
BIDEN AND HILLARY CLINTON AND
EVERYTHING LIKE THAT, WAY WORSE
THAN DEPLORABLES OR YOU DON'T
LIKE THEM, AND NO ONE SEEMS TO
CARE.
THE DEEP OFFENSE WHEN PEOPLE
CALL THEM MAGA PEOPLE, AND I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHY.
>> JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN GETTING
FLAK AND GETTING HIT FROM
DEMOCRATS, DIE HARD DEMOCRATS,
AND PROGRESSIVES ABOUT BEING TOO
SOFT, I THINK, ON DONALD TRUMP
WHICH IS INTERESTING.
IT HAS BECOME THIS IDEA OF THE
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
WHAT I THINK IS INTERESTING IS
GIVEN JAMIE DIMON HAS BEEN SO
CRITICAL IN THE PAST WHY THE
ABOUT-FACE?
WHY IN THIS MOMENT?
WHY SO RAPIDLY ESPECIALLY WHEN
HE SPENT THE LAST THREE MONTHS
CHAMPIONING NIKKI HALEY SAYING
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO IS NOT
CHAOTIC, WHO IS NOT SPITTING IN
PEOPLE'S FACES AND CALLING
PEOPLE NAMES OR FALLING FOR, YOU
KNOW, REVENGE POLITICS AS THE
FRONT -- AS A FRONT-RUNNER OF
THE PARTY.
PART OF WHAT WE HAVE TO LOOK
INTO IS WHAT DOES JAMIE DIMON
SEE AS THE PATHWAY FORWARD?
IS HE -- ONE OF THE THINGS HE'S
IDENTIFYING, HE THINKS TRUMP IS
GOING TO BE THE FRONT-RUNNER.
>> HE DIDN'T SAY THAT.
>> HE SAYS THIS IS THE PERSON
THAT IS GOING TO BE THE GOP
NOMINEE.
I THINK AS HE'S THINKING
ABOUT -- AS WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
HOW IS HE FRAMING THIS, WE HAVE
TO REMEMBER THAT JAMIE DIMON IS
TRYING TO THINK ABOUT AN
ENTRYWAY INTO THIS RELATIONSHIP
WITH TRUMP.
>> CAN I ASK YOU A QUESTION, AND
THIS IS ABOUT SEPARATING THE
POLICIES THAT HE LAID OUT THERE,
WHETHER IT'S WITH NATO, WHETHER
IT'S ON IMMIGRATION, THE
ECONOMY, CHINA, AND THE WORDS
THE FORMER PRESIDENT CHOOSES TO
USE, THE WAY HE DOES IT, DO YOU
SEE WHAT I'M SAYING?
CAN YOU SEE A SEPARATION THERE?
OR IS IT TAKE IT ALL OR LEAVE IT
ALL?
>> I THINK JAMIE DIMON SAYS WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO SEPARATE.
>> RIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT I'M ASKING.
>> THE PROBLEM IS, SOMEONE LIKE
TRUMP -- I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
SUPPORTERS.
THAT'S A DIFFERENT CONVERSATION.
WITH SOMEONE LIKE TRUMP, THERE
IS NO SEPARATION.
I THINK IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
ESSENTIALLY MAKE AN ARGUMENT
THAT IS EFFECTIVELY WHITE
WASHING THE PRESIDENT'S IDEAS
AND POLICIES.
THIS WAS ONE OF JAMIE DIMON'S
CENTRAL CRITICISMS.
MAYBE TRUMP IS RIGHT ABOUT
IMMIGRATION.
TWO YEARS AGO HE WAS BLASTING
THE PRESIDENT FOR HIS STANCE ON
IMMIGRATION IN THE WAY THAT HE
IS TALKING ABOUT IMMIGRANTS.
YOU CAN'T DIVORCE THE TWO.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT HAS TO BE
EVALUATED ALONGSIDE HOW WE ARE
THINKING OF RUNNING THIS
ARGUMENT ABOUT AN EXISTENTIAL
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
>> I THINK IT'S A FASCINATING
CONVERSATION.
>> ME, TOO.
TOO BAD WE HAVE COMMERCIALS.
>> RUINING EVERYTHING.
DeSANTIS TRIED TO RUN THE TRUM